and if I sound down right now well it's
because Drew Brees got hurt man he got
hurt and you know you could just and
it's so funny I was watching the game
and the Saint this New Orleans Saints
and the Los Angeles Rams who most people
even have not even heard of that team
but they were going at it and it was
exciting right in the beginning and and
then drew Brees got hurt and it was so
funny I would have rather dois CH when
the camera would cut to him
you got to see somebody you know here he
has he's 40 years old and and the injury
looks kind of like it could be bad you
know he couldn't even pick up a football
and it just
he couldn't even grip that frickin pig
that little that little you know
deceased brown pig getting it crazy that
a football is a pig that he used to be a
pig and now it's just you know they cut
off the head and tied off the ends of it
and put those white you know try to kind
of give it some white stitches or
something by the liver and now they're
throwing it around man I mean this you
know we think we're so far removed from
what is it called uh not the Ice Age or
something but um
bestiality no you know we think we're so
far removed from I don't know what it's
called Neolithic the Neo pale uh old
days the old days let's agree with that
we think we're so far removed from the
old days but then here you see you know
but once I guys throwing around that uh
just throwing around that that little
ripped up swine chunk and you're like
damn we are we are still we are a little
bit stuck in the past you know but uh
was I talking about but yeah but drew
brees got hurt in and at some point I
was enjoying not enjoying but I was
there was more every
the camera cut to him and it was just so
much it was more entertaining than the
game because I was watching this man who
had you know this was a man who had the
world on his back and who you could tell
how this how determined he was and how
focused he was in every game you can
tell it like he's playing the game but
he's also playing this bigger game like
what he's doing right now always seems
like just a move in a grander scheme of
his life like and he's able to do both
at the same time it always seems like
and you were just seeing him just how
limited he was by the circuit by the by
the moment you know you could see him
and he couldn't and how limited he was
by his vessel by his own body he
couldn't grip that hand he couldn't
closed that hand up and he couldn't grip
a football and he couldn't express
himself you know when you started to
just see a man that was limited by you
know it's like even whatever that desire
that fire inside of us that that want
you know where it's all limited a little
bit by the Raviv the reality by the
actuality of what's going on by
circumstance and and man that was a much
greater game to me was just seeing the
look in his eyes the mental game that it
was going on inside of him trying to
hold his composure and trying to trying
to almost in the moment find out who he
was when suddenly he was you is when
suddenly the the path he had been on
came to an abrupt like there weren't any
more there was no more paths for it just
came to it like a cul-de-sac and you
were trying he had just so much energy
so many people behind him soon I mean so
many Saints fans you saw him winning a
championship again you saw him you know
you already had these visions of him I
hugging his kids again under the
whatever that is paper the paper the
little paper rain
[ __ ] man my brain is a stalled out dude
what is my brain a Datsun the [ __ ] is
[ __ ] needs oil but you saw him stalled
out the confetti you saw you know and
you just saw and suddenly everything
stopped man all of it it just and you
saw him trying to find out from or
that's what I saw saw man is struggling
to know who he was at this moment when
the world had taken you know a different
a different turn you know when when the
reality that whatever we want always
isn't what's going to happen or that
things aren't going to work out
perfectly or that when reality strikes
you know a man and it broke your heart
as a fan it broke your heart as a human
I feel like to see someone with so much
capability and so many people who look
up to him or look at him as a figure of
Direction an example and suddenly he you
see him come almost even though he
didn't put himself into the atmosphere
you see him and and and I did I put him
up in the atmosphere I put him up you
see him come back down to earth and it's
uh I don't know it was man it was it was
hectic man that was a hectic moment and
the day that the druze ik the druze ik
died that's that's an old song nobody
even knew this [ __ ] whatever dude good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one